welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in Rick and Morty season 4 episode
4 claw and horror special victims Morty
is filled with subtle animation details
and hidden jokes theand look past the
[ __ ] dragons they pull a lot of focus
they can pull any part of me they want
yeah sorry
distracted arrested no just distracted
we'll see let's break down all the stuff
that you might have missed this episode
it's where the warning if you have not
seen it yet
ok this episode opens with Morty fleeing
guards with chachi some cat like alien
companion who helped Morty escape from
prison with the ultimate cube a
backstory that we may never know more
about because his brains get blown out
the animators include a shot of Rick
framed through the wound an angle they
used in the pickle Rick episode Rick
ain't thrilled with this throwaway
MacGuffin
oh it's purple you said it was purple
said mine was I didn't know they all
were be able to make cube is a take on
the tesseract of the MCU which is blue
color-coded with the rainbow spectrum of
colors that the other Infinity stones
have Morty demands a dragon who's into
dragons Morty nerds that refuse to admit
their Christian very true but also a nod
to banda see riders like CS lewis a
devout Christian and theologists and
others like Tolkien and george RR martin
who claimed to avoid lewis's christian
symbolism but nonetheless fell into
christ figures throughout their
mythologies more teach I'll additionally
repeats himself this calls back the
famous Simpsons episode where part
repeatedly demanded the elephant he was
promised
[Applause]
hey plane elephants dog Morty gets his
dragon with a blood oath from the wizard
he grants him a dragon spell book which
Morty carries around similar to the book
in the neverending story and Morty gets
his dragon
my name is ball trauma breaker of sky
Slayer of monkeys mother dragon style
titles are not to this dragon be voiced
by Liam Cunningham aka sir Davos
Seaworth from Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones is one of the many dragon
properties parodied this episode Morty's
flights definitely reflects John and
Danny's stupid flight in the final
season premiere as well as the Falkor
flight and the neverending story in the
mini flight sequences in the How to
Train Your Dragon series and of course
Harry Potter writing the Hippogriff in
the Prisoner of Azkaban the running joke
of this episode is the modern popularity
of dragons is weirdly erotic and
masturbatory masking a subculture of
dragon fetishists that trust me you
don't want a Google later when Rick's
soul bonds with both Rama it's similar
to the bonding between Navi to be suit
every nand avatar Jerry asks Rick about
a talking cat and Rick shrugs it off
you're talking to a cat it's an abnormal
event unrelated to me like when you went
to Pluto or my daughter
Jerry's visit to Pluto is a callback to
the B story of these something Rick it
this way comes episode in which Jerry
got mixed up in Pluto's environmental
politics this talking cat is voiced by
Matthew Broderick maybe it's time you
stopped asking questions and started
having fun the cat has left a bit of a
mystery this episode with some
stomach-turning backstory that we never
see the writers say he's based on the
cats of animated movies like oliver and
company who talk without explanation
others say it could be a nod to the cat
from outer space movie or that it's mr.
Bhuvan boodles cat though that cat has a
different fur pattern on its nose this
one is a dick shape on its nose which I
use as evidence for you really a
backstory for this cat that I went into
in this week's episode of Rick's laned
with Brandon Johnson voice of mr.
goldenfold to go check it out
when Morty returns with his dragon you
could see more bees and Rick's graves in
the backyard
those were from when they killed and
buried the alternate versions themselves
at the end of Rick potion number 9 Rick
and summer watches show called ass which
is not de bones and this episode's title
claw and hoarder special victims Morty
is a nod to another procedural law and
order SVU
co-starring I steam a key water T of
Alpha beat reham Rick confronts the
dragon who lounges on his hoarded riches
like smog from The Hobbit
among these treasures are a vintage hi-c
ecto cooler also some ones that are
harder to spot the toy soldiers spin
pops a Dan Harmon Funko pop figure
Action Comics number one that was the
first appearance of Superman a lunchbox
with duck man from the 90s animated
series the forest era cassette tape from
over the garden wall a cork oscillator
pro tablet VR goggles a Tesla the venus
de milo statue and a Banksy painting
brick marvels at a side future vinyl
album and latest episode Rick and the
dragon party - future's masked off they
blow off Morty with an animated gif of
Taylor Swift and they free some zoo
animals you can notice Rick bothers in
giraffe maybe a nod to the orgy had with
the giraffe in the autoerotic
assimilation episode looking for
judgement just say yes or no can you
assimilate a giraffe meanwhile Jerry
flies the talking cat to Florida to play
volleyball on the beach as a Florida
refugee I can tell you that no beach in
Florida specifically one on the Gulf
Coast since they later face the coast of
the Sun setting to the west of them no
beach in Florida has hills or cliffs the
whole coastline of the state is very
very flat but clearly the animators
basis on the west coast of Southern
California among this beach party is an
adult Ash Ketchum for Pokemon along with
an adult tummy pickles from Rugrats
neither of whom each - well all the
other dudes are Molina level jacked I
love how the animators included many of
these characters farmer stands very
Florida thing Rick and the Dragons soul
bond orgasmically and the wizard returns
notice how he's adjusting his robe as he
comes through the portal later this
episode we'll see that whenever he's
summoned he's always in the middle of
his own [ __ ] sash with pieces to
slut-shame belt Rama as a bone hilt and
Rick calls him dandruff the gray an odd
tooth Gandalf the gray and the wizard
summons a stone monster teleports away
with a lightning bridge which is a lot
like the Bifrost of Asgard in a Marvel
Universe actually in the MCU the magic
of Asgard is defined by Thor as science
and their eyes and a similar debate
between science and magic unfolds
between Rick and wizards
monster was here to introduce the
physicists as Rick did with the trash
and rat parts in the pickle Rick episode
he engineers the device to convert his
situation into scientific units he can
use his proton pack style magic
converter is awesome to see in action
against these orcs and the dragon are
key which is a volcanic setting very
similar to Mordor one of the orc says
that big ass and Rick and plates a bunch
of other orcs similar to Harry Potter's
inflation spell in Prisoner of Azkaban
and some are pops them with our arrows
Rick converts an orc to a football and
punts it he converts another to a
flowerpot maybe a nod to Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy when an enemy
missile is converted into a bowl of
petunias curiously the only thing that
went through the mind of the bowl of
petunias is it fell was oh no not again
one is turned into a bird another into a
pig another into a rooster and then
another into a bottle of booze and then
another into a bowling ball which he
bowls into others then he turns into
pins which is in turns into butterflies
and then into Easter eggs for us to find
but Summers cocky error work leads to
both Rama and Rick getting hit in the
eye and the wizard to beat up Rick with
a power of 12 feet meanwhile in Florida
the talking cat tries to mingle on the
yacht party you can see an adult Ash
Ketchum smoking a bong and there's drugs
and alcohol everywhere whose Oh
lines of coke everyone smoking a joint
there's a plate of pot brownies a
typical Florida Monday and others hide
in the dragon [ __ ] cave beneath the
ground you can see there's Dragons
skeletons buried there and they meet the
other [ __ ] dragons including Deborah and
Michael who bully mammoths yes and I
love how Debra shoes him away by waving
her way at him in summer rallies them
this man with a ponytail
makes a valid point this could be an
in-joke to the discovery fans have made
that Sommers character design is
essentially Jerry with a ponytail and
then their elder is shadow jacker each
high time I emerge from my cocoon I grow
tired of eavesdropping and masturbating
to the sound you all make his staff is a
sex toy on the end and I just love they
included a wet squishy sound in the mix
whenever he walks with it and now the
slit dragons Voltron together in a soul
orgy forming a Phoenix dragon force that
destroys the wizard and the other
dragons
Rick mocks the writing on the portal
since his portals never have writing on
them he's referencing how the portals in
like Doctor Strange and other properties
have these mystical text and runes
floating around them and upon returning
Rick realizes that jerry's talking cat
is a real problem I better check on him
big season finale right there you know
given the cat's dark past being left a
mystery you may very well be seeing him
again but Rick flies very in the cat out
to the desert quantum radiator might
need some nano water this is a callback
to Rick's joke in the Microverse episode
quantum carburetor Jesus Morty you can't
just add a sci-fi word you lack R word
and hope it means something huh looks
like something's wrong with the
Microverse battery and if you're curious
what this talking cat really could have
done again check out the Rick's planed
episode for my depth Theory there Rick
clears this awful memory from Jerry's
mind by using the same mind blower
device from the season 3 Morty's
mind-blower episode end of the
post-credits scene when bell trauma
sadly tries to soul bond with anyone
who's interested there's one more hidden
Dicky here one of the graffiti on the
wall before he throws his riches in
front of it what do you think the cat's
dark backstory is comment down below
with your thoughts and a reminder to
check out new rockstars new Q&A show the
big question it's really fun new format
where we tackle the nerdiest questions
by throwing scary levels of math and
science at them check it out
I'm real proud of it thank you for
joining me bye bye
[Music]